good morning everyone ooh feeling kind
of seasick in my nautical shirt no but
if you guys could see it for there but
my shirt has anchors on it and I'm so
separated have you worn this shirt on
the show yeah I bought it for Turks and
Caicos and every time I tried it out
interesting hey guys I'm like oh this is
an ugly shirt and then I'm like okay
well where can I wear it where I don't
give a [ __ ] where I look Allah this
morning well thank you for gracing us
bringing a little summer index I mean
I'm very spring as you guys know it's
dirty jeans again five days in a row
nothing to be concerned about but I like
to change up the top my shirt my shoes
are always open for for interpretation
pants just assume it's true when you
start wearing dirty tops five days and
around bed and we have a problem you
know dirty jeans five days in a row is
like a cultural phenomenon like it's not
a big deal it's nothing to be alarmed
about nothing to be ashamed of
truthfully you know where's dirty jeans
five days in Iran really yes she told me
I feel like though technically wearing
dirty jeans five days in a row is less
sanitary than wearing a dirty shirt five
days right because I did the China and
like you sit on stuff your butt and they
get dirty baby like your your breasts
don't get through it unless you like
lactating I guess no it's a good point
it's dirty bra five years in a row years
centuries I never have a same bra I was
like when I walked out of the womb
no like once you get the bra for you
company never take it off Dominique best
bra brand for uh speak to them and if
you're in New York and you have big tits
you're barrel chested woman and don't
know what to do about it
go trick or treat searching your phone
bright oh the Orchard Street course a
corset shop it's a religious Jewish
couple the woman literally she's like
she looks through you she's like I'm
like I need to get measured she goes I'm
not gonna say my size but she was like
none of that and like it was bright no
but she makes you they take your bra she
just looks to you tells you your size
gives you the perfect bra and they're
like this chain and then you're her
husband like checks you out yeah it's
just not like that he like rings you up
oh yeah no not like hey girl yeah it's
the closest thing to magic you can
possibly hold oh how did we get here
dirty jeans have a zero right right
right before that your nautical top yeah
because we're on the
oh yeah you don't care how you look oh
right but speaking of how I look I have
a couple announcements oh okay well
that's great because I need a break
already cuz I'm ready sir statesman is
after we make some rave reviews some
personal friends of mine and then
Brittney Cartwright I've officially
decided to get kybella cuz like I'm
saying Jackie like I'm so confident like
I love the way that I look but like when
I look in pictures like then what
everyone has like one thing that like
like hate about themselves I mean it's
like my chin of my neck I'm like yes I
know if I love waited like ever to my
double chin like [ __ ] you I don't want
to and I've just decided this is the way
I'm gonna look for my life and like I
want to get rid my chin okay I'm proud
of you and I'm I support this is such a
nervous come on very low tolerance for
someone who is looking into my own
cosmetic surgeries I support your
decision and I just feel like it's like
that time in my life like TMZ wrote me
up I'm ready for surgery like it's just
it's it's an evolution and this is the
natural next step
yeah like that was the chicken this is
that exactly or that was the egg um so
yeah I'm ready I know it's expensive so
I need to save up so keep subscribing to
our page so I can get both funny
hilarious singing of patreon though we
recorded and released our first episode
yesterday and the critics did the room
the crowd has gone wild
honestly he was like a really like
one-on-one like we just had lunches we
were full we were sitting on my couch
like it was just one-on-one Jackie O
England's military I never seen them
before raw uncut in the nude yeah and he
was we spoke about a lot of things we
spoke about like a lot about what people
have kind of been like wanting us to
talk about but we don't want to taint
like this beautiful show with like
things of the past
let me spoke a lot about the break we
spoke a lot about the bribe you spoke a
lot about like how we grew up we spoke a
lot about what we were doing before the
show yeah no it's really interesting so
if you are a patron subscriber you
haven't listened to it go ahead and
listen and if you are in a patreon
subscriber and you have 8 bucks a month
you want to throw in my pocket gopher
patreon.com/scishow morning toast we
took all questions from the morning
toasters group and I feel like now that
people realize that we literally
answered every single question and that
nothing was off-limits we should do
another episode where they ask us the
things that they really want to know you
know so I've been getting a lot of DM so
Jackie's like the main moderator in the
group like you let people in and like
I'd get been getting a lot of questions
like people like I've been trying to get
in the group play three weeks oh this is
what happened
we went on vacation and they stopped
exam but so are you still accepting boys
okay I just didn't have the bandwidth to
thoroughly vet people which I do by the
way much bye-bye hi my you yeah very
okay first story well we here are the
fast 5 stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of that morning toast
I actually I have six stories today what
you know means it's a it's a slow news
day yeah surprise Caitlyn Jenner 68 will
reportedly Wed girlfriend Sophia
Hutchins 21 this summer oh wait Wow hold
on
60 yeah she looks to me she's older than
Ramona and she looks amazing I don't
know why Ramona has become like my bar
about the benchmark for six-year-olds
and honestly that's a high bar to live
up to so Caitlyn is 70 and Sophia is 21
yeah that's a 50-year age difference
that's wild that's so big like I don't
only think it's a big deal and like
there's like a 20-year age difference me
neither like Wow well I'm gonna believe
this article because there's some weeks
you see nuggets that I just can't
believe I've been sleeping on this
relationship for so long that I didn't
know about it and you know what I blame
the best kisser everyone was like
talking about Caitlyn when Caitlyn was
like the belle of the ball and now that
the Kardashians have tossed her aside
they can go into I smashed style and
radar so only people covering Caitlyn's
wedding know but also like just
Caitlyn's like like how did I not know
that Caitlyn was in a relationship I
literally have like Google search on our
team is really private no but like ever
since she became like a woman she's been
like loving being public and like that's
true out there okay apparently age is
just a number for Caitlyn Jenner and
Sophia Hutchins the couple who are
nearly 50 years apart are reportedly
planning on tying the knot this summer a
source told radar online so maybe this
is all fake and that's what I haven't
heard about it they considered it
impossible they consider each other
soulmates and freely admit they couldn't
imagine a life with anyone else at this
point they added that the couple plan to
say I do this summer in your Kate's
Malibu mansion with a handful of close
friends and family members probably a
family member yeah like Kendall no I'm
Brody know kind of Bert Bert but don't
expect the Kardashians to get an invite
this is a dream come true for Kate
because her rejection by the Kardashians
and even her own
daughters had left her feeling isolated
suffering from a crippling depression
Sophia has changed all that honestly I'm
really happy for her but I go back and
forth deserves happiness because like I
imagine that being abandoned by your
family and like one of the most I mean I
don't even know what it's like to
transition but I've been one of the most
emotional and difficult times like ever
like can be a lot but I think she also
did a lot of like shed day better in
watch it so like I don't know whose side
to take when it comes to Kaitlyn I know
because she comes off like so sweet
menacing in all of her interviews and
all she wants is like to be herself and
with her family and it's a-you know all
the Kardashians want is to be able to
like have a good relationship with her
right so why is it what's not what are
we missing
we're missing something not to mention
the car jenner clan doesn't exactly
approve of her new leading lady in
december a source told Life & Style
exclusively that Caitlyn starters Kylie
and Kendall and Kim Kardashian were
upset about their relationship quote
they've heard from friends at Caitlyn
stating Sophia and it upsets them like
you wouldn't believe
they continued she's their age how would
you feel if your father was seeing
someone your age it always comes back to
chutney it always comes back to Linda
Cardellini and that's it always come
talk to Freaks and Geeks really that's
what I'm realizing illa mix them
telecine is charts about it keep in mind
Sophia is in between Kendall and Kylie's
ages which is crazy it's just honestly
like disgusting it's it's crazy okay I
just like I said I don't know where
where to fall with Caitlyn like I think
she's an important figure in our culture
cuz I think she's like teaching a lot of
people about what it means to be
transgender and she's like educating the
world and she's really important in that
like her Diane Sawyer resident I don't
even remember I interviewed her spatula
change the world
no no I mean I was literally dying like
the whole time cuz I thought it wasn't
real like until no until that interview
like her journey was just like this
public up for public consumption people
were saying the meanest things about her
and in that moment everybody felt
differently like the meanest people like
we're no longer mean and like everyone
accepted her and I think it was just
such a major moment in American history
yes and by fighting in our culture she's
like an important figure but when it
comes like her personal life and like
have over lights to the Kardashians like
I don't believe her yeah I don't think
the Kardashians would ever like
intentionally isolate like look how long
they even they keep Rob around even
though he literally like brought the
devil into their home's and made a baby
with the devil
and they still keep Rob around so what
the [ __ ] did Caitlyn do that was so
unforgiving because he wasn't like he
said such terrible things about Kris oh
sorry
and when they him when he could you yes
but yes I think when like you cannot
come progress no no and nobody does now
they think about it like and it's like
China never came for Chris yeah because
China respects the hell out of Chris
Jenna so do we
so whenever comfort this show respects
the hell out of GMA respects the hell
out of us and we respect the hell out of
Chris Jenner yeah and everyone who calls
her like the devil working harder please
stop I just hate that phrase right like
no at first it was funny and I was like
they say for everything right every time
like a Kardashian farts yeah Kris Jenner
works harder but um any additional
thoughts on Caitlyn no I mean I'm happy
for her I wish her happiness but like
this seems weird yeah and I'm not one to
cast aspersions at other people's
relationships but I'm going to but I'm
also happy for her
everyone deserves happiness yes
especially Kate because she doesn't have
many people in her life right now I know
it's like really sad it is really sad I
feel like she's like has an empty life I
don't know what it's like she had a
reality show and like it wasn't and
people didn't even want to watch it okay
like I'm not like I watch it and I
didn't even want to watch it no I me too
because I think the most interesting
part was like I had already happened and
like Bruce was never that interesting of
a guy like neither is feeling like it's
just what what they went through was
interesting but Caitlyn herself is not
like an interesting person I agree and
you know what is interesting though what
in the comments like people are really
not feeling with story move on let's go
down that's why we have six so we could
discard one United Airlines is facing
imminent lawsuit over suffocated a dog
story literally brings tears to my eyes
also the story is like a losers because
when you first heard it you were like
that
flight attendant really [ __ ] up like
and that's pure evil but apparently the
flight attendant I don't know if as a
man or a woman didn't know there was a
dog in the bag she was like put your bag
up but not she didn't realize it was a
dog in the bag she would have never said
to put your dog up I didn't read that
I'd read that well that changes
everything
well like what a [ __ ] passengers speak
up right right apparently the dog was
barking her sick
right oh so there's the truck it's not
that people said she knew there was next
time people said they didn't I'm sure
that's her defense because it's like
image barking why did the flight
attendant nothing to ask like hey sir
why is your bag barking no but I think
maybe was barking when it was put up and
then you're just hearing a barking dog
on a plane you're like I can't explain
it like I just there's so many times
where like I wish I was there
I wouldn't expect just to clear things
up I would be like lady the dogs gonna
die take him out people handle it like I
just like there's so many places I just
like wish I was like the elevator with
Beyonce and jay-z like and little
Solange like I just I know I could have
like mediated like I don't know there's
just like so many places like I wish I
was for like the sake of our society I
mean and this is one of them however
this is a horrible horrible story oh but
I also wish I was like on Sully yeah I
would've gotten the dogs out there were
no dogs
trick question I do not wish I was on
telly but anyone who's like the also you
know that Southwest had another plane
with an engine that exploded and pierced
a window and had to have an emergency
landing but no one died think that's why
I applied to Alta because your plane
never makes it out here's the thing
about this story it's a horrible story
and I hope that justice is served
I don't even know how justice what
justice being served what he would like
but I do hope that this forces Airlines
to rethink how they treat animals in
general dogs going being checked dogs
going in the overhead and honestly dogs
going under the seat it's not it's not a
solution there needs to be a little
doggie area I totally a doggie playpen I
mean it's definitely any vibes you buy a
ticket for your dog we'll see that's the
thing like we definitely made strides
like back in the day like when we were
kids like you would check dogs and it
was like not a big deal but like we've
become a little bit more humane and like
it's crazy
I've been even putting them under the
seat is crazy but like having to
purchase another seat is like not an
option for most people so like they're
just there needs to be a better way well
putting them under the seat isn't even
that bad it's just like only only toy
dogs fit under the seat so now you're
discriminating against the odds based on
their body type
yeah which is body shaming in the animal
community you should be able to buy a
seat for your dog in the play area give
hundred dollars per dog and that should
be good and they'll give them
treats and the directly with the other
dogs and I've never flown with Co but I
imagine like I don't know he would just
be so good like I would buy us a
first-class seat and me would just
snuggle the whole time it sounds amazing
right but like not everyone has the jump
up and not everybody buys food yeah he
would be raucous no I literally will
never fly with him he loves cars like
we're going to the Hamptons for a week
me and Ben and Ben's family and the
house is pet friendly and has like a
huge yard and like a fence and like I'm
just you know like when we booked it
last night like confirmed and like when
I found out like do you know no so
excited about SEOs drive there feels car
ride like he loves the car and like me
and but I love driving with Ben because
like we just have the best time like we
eat so many snacks and like you know I
can't eat so many snacks with you on you
that's true that's true no exactly man
like I'm gonna make him like a whole bed
situation in the back cuz like it's just
a three of us are you gonna open the
window oh my god the old loves window
but whatever comes out he won't do
anyone I don't know those those roads
get windy so precious goodies we need we
need reform for travel system should we
like write a bill write a bill use your
spell hasit bruisers but we called
Theo's bill no it has to be come I can't
believe there hasn't been a piece of
legislation called bruisers bill yeah I
know
also and she's shot in Washington on
Iran with animal testing with like going
against animal testing and if she
doesn't write a bill called bruisers
bill then all hope is lost
do I just him believe honestly Reese
Witherspoon hasn't like gone to the
Capitol right or like this when like the
Capitol members saw Legally Blonde -
they weren't like how do we not pastors
right but were they inspired like we
were they should have been he mishit -
my button all the way up like my collar
sure we'll see you didn't do it no but
like I'm mimicking oh no it looks very
professional okay so that was our second
story my injustice when we purchased the
oh he was from Dallas and the Texas boy
there was an option they were like well
how do you want to get him you can fly
to go get him we send him via United pet
safe or we can have like someone fly
with him take him Embry I'm Gio and I'll
just say did that even though
more expensive because like what the
hell is safe it sounds very unsafe
unsafe yeah yeah or American small puppy
hit stomach what a flip
oh my god totally he was so small like
we I've been looking back at old
pictures like when he showed up to your
bridal shower he was sick that day and
he was it was the day after you got him
yeah and he was so small and frail and
scared he was so scared and he had tics
yeah yeah okay let's get to this next
story another week story for a weekday
well Prince Harry's Exodus christed a
bonus and Chelsea DPP guests at his
wedding
let me guess no I don't know let's see
how he had on-again off-again
relationships with Davi for several
years in his early mid 20s with their
last his time to reconciliation come i
hate when the article title is a
question it's like now i need to me to
answer hold on please
I love that girl it's yes okay oh here
here's there's all trusted heirs royal
precedent for inviting our exes to your
big day Prince William welcome five of
his reported past 2001 wedding to Kate
don't care about all their names and of
course that is wedding to Princess Diana
Prince Charles invited Camilla wait that
girl Chelsea I really had high hopes or
have it Harry likes odious so did I like
I said I just like bread about them in a
magazine like fell in love with this
girl she was and I tried to find her on
Instagram but she was not but she was
too cool I just thought they would end
up together anyway why you say a
quintessential socialite and like that's
just what I've always wanted to be
totally but it's weird cuz he's had so
many girlfriends and it's like in my
mind this was his only girlfriend and
that's so weird that it was the same for
you yeah I know wait show me her you
know that face yeah glamour collab today
totally should have been together but
he's with Megan now and Megan's brother
wrote a letter
I put an open letter to Prince Harry
saying and they said don't marry Megan
it's at Harry when you were sleeping
Megan went to bed and put his head
between do god that's so funny I don't
know when that letter like won't be
relevant I don't want to live in a time
where it's not relevant I agree
I just can't wait for the royal wedding
and we need to solidify our plans for
you because we're having
we're have we're gonna obviously do
round-the-clock Royale coverage just
depends from where and like where are we
streaming or like how long look at the
Saturday and it's like we won't you know
turn the camera off but like can we just
sit and watch for a little bit like to
be honest hard and I feel like we need
to do it in a bed or something because
like it's gonna be really early yeah or
late we should be at your apartment I
think so too
we don't need a studio like we've got a
big British flag behind us hold on those
little hat let's get like a British flag
comforter and like sleep in my bed or
let's get like a briefcase that says box
number four I think was 24 though was it
I mean I think she was more she was hit
more than once yeah
okay still excited for the royal wedding
we'll talk about it then yeah it's like
there's a panic a lot of drama
surrounding her and like the wedding
where it's like at someone who's just
like reading the headlines like you
would think that they are just like so
what it was yeah
and she was like men this was the role
she was born to play well
obviously the role that she was born to
play is the FedEx girl in her bosses of
course but this is like a secondary role
that she'll be good at okay Briana
sizzles in chainmail dress as she talks
about bad days and freezing her eggs
while hunting billionaire beau is the
one in smoldering vote shoot so
Rihanna's coming out with new music soon
right because she's been like do no but
now she's what's down low yeah I know
now she's like in the public she's you
need me but I'm saying she hasn't had
music since aunty which was like three
years ago was it yeah that's crazy I
feel like every time she doesn't have
music god it's like everyone's waiting
for her music come out where is like
other art it like Christina Aguilera
apparently hadn't put a song on in six
years who knows she released a song
today I didn't even know but I know that
Rihanna like I'm waiting for music yeah
no we actually but if we're gonna have
like wow wow
oh yeah and four or five seconds like
she was on other people's songs yeah
four or five seconds when you record an
album with Paul McCartney and it becomes
a single furry on it did you hear that
only the best song do you kindly said
they was associating hey when did he say
it Charlie yeah at towards the end to
finish the Charlamagne it was just it's
very long and it's very Sherman like
wasn't keeping up and like neither was I
it's very dense
yeah very dense with like that ugly
furniture but that's King's house I know
I honestly like I got into it I thought
they filmed at her house sometimes she
apparently and never lets cameras in our
house after the robbery there was a
couple episodes where like you see her
in bed and stuff and like that's not her
house I don't know like her house is
like a mausoleum maybe they moved since
then maybe but it's like all white
off-white like Virgil maybe Vettel
designed it it's honestly so ugly and
looks so uncomfortable but I tried and I
just they're the Kardashian like style
that they have for all their house like
they look the same on the outside and
inside it's like really like expensive
lush modern furniture like it's like my
dream and like what is that like weird
tears
yeah but dining room chairs aren't
supposed to be comfortable I hope they
have a comfortable couch Oh bed yeah
maybe like a restoration like they would
go like
she's a force to be reckoned with
outside of the music world after
launching her successful funky beauty
brand after adding new strings to her
ever-growing brand's bow Rihanna has
turned her attention to the dazzling
latest Vogue cover where she discusses
Fatty's freezing her eggs and finding
the one the 30 year old musical
powerhouse wow she's only 30 she's been
around
excuse me along tsubame today's yeah she
was dancing to that song on her
Instagram story the other day I don't
have the energy to sing today because
everybody run run Tim and I will meet
guys outside but by then I could get me
a ride
if you ready to move say yeah yeah yeah
buddy yeah mine yeah yeah I'm ready for
ya I'm Amish oh yeah you want to move
pretty good pagan she recently how many
times she know it's obviously really
impressive frente uh okay well you know
what they're not gonna tell us what she
actually said they're just gonna all I
want to hear is about the fat days what
did she say hey admitting that she
doesn't feel any wiser now that she's
reached the milestone of 30 she asked
okay so now that I'm 30 are there things
I'm supposed to do should I be worried
should I be freezing my eggs what do you
do at 13 nothing you just live with you
okay sorry you guys just figure it out
okay well whatever
I love Rihanna I can't wait for her new
music me too I love Rihanna and more
importantly I love thick Rihanna totally
but I Donna but like she's not good
because sometimes she's sick sometimes
she's thin she doesn't care either way
what she looks like
like at least like I'm sure she feels a
certain way sometimes because she's
human but like she never lets it stop
her like say she's having a quote fat
day like she's still going to the Met
Gala
I totally agree I just love Rihanna and
I think she's a pioneer in beauty in
fashion in music and in life and it's
like she was on all of the songs that
were like starting drama like famous and
the Calvin Harris song let me tell her
something like she remained above it oh
yeah like that's so interesting you know
because Calvin Harris this is whatever
remember how tariffs wrote the song
Rhian was featured on it and then
Rihanna was also on famous or Kanye
listen Keller and like she just remained
out of it I mean what is Rihanna he's
that's so true she's on to diss tracks
for Taylor Swift what do you think her
relationship is with Taylor I'm sure
that she's literally like never met the
girl it doesn't have her number it
doesn't give a [ __ ] wouldn't be
surprised if she doesn't even know who
she is yeah totally
what do you think Taylor Swift think
some Brianna I'm sure Taylor Swift loves
Rihanna because she actually like has
good taste in icons and I feel like I
can see Taylor and Kim coming together
once again I think so too because Kanye
in the Sharla meme and I mean which I
only watch a little of he like spoke on
Taylor Swift a lot did he yeah he likes
that part no in the beginning he was
like ever since the Taylor thing like my
songs haven't been playing on the radio
and he like insinuated that I had
something to do with like hers her being
in charge of like the powers that be
I need this boy he like mentioned it a
couple times almost like you were read
of it I don't think she has that much
power she's like I didn't think so
either but he basically said a lot of
part part of his like breakdown was that
like you work so hard on this album like
every person was listening to it every
person was streaming it like every
famous person came to the concert and
snapchat II and like it wasn't being
played on the radio and like when you're
an R&B artist like the radio it means
everything like being played on the
radio means like you've made it
and he's like none of my songs got
played on the radio and like I thought
it had a lot to do with like the powers
that be when I did the toe strap thing
and blah blah but I forgot where I was
coming with that uh I forget that you
could see them coming together have you
yeah except like he's definitely sorry
for the grabbing the my thing but she's
definitely not sorry for the lying and
being like a snake wellhere's I so
passed the grabbing the mic thing it's
about what came releasing the tapes no
but but I and I think it wasn't wrong in
releasing them no but like Taylor like
lied and set him up and made him look
like an [ __ ] when he really did the
right thing yeah
then I'm Tim Taylor always except when
it comes to this particular scenario
because homegirl was wrong I don't know
I feel of two minds on it like on the
one hand Kim released the tapes and it
proves that Taylor knew that she was
gonna be on it and that they were there
was gonna be a line about her but there
were two lines about her so like I don't
know it's very confusing but I could see
Kim like wanting to reconcile with
Taylor because honest
Kym's above everything yeah but I don't
think Taylor will ever forget that point
yeah her for a year for a year and like
it just it confirmed what everyone
thought about Taylor Swift was that she
was like this manipulative calculated
[ __ ] impress because look she was like
she knew about the song she knew about
the line and pretended like there was
this whole surprise like she
orchestrated it into this whole thing
and then we got this video number like
oh no it wasn't that you are the lying
sleuth that everyone says you are
yeah but like it confirmed so many
things like and I feel like she really
lost a lot of fans for it cuz like
people who stand Kim like also Stan
Taylor like we have similar fans like
you couldn't not be on Kim's side like
homegirl lied and made Kayne West look
like a bad person and he's not yeah
that's all I'm saying
I agree and then don't get me wrong I
stand tell her like I love her I'm going
to her concert like I'm gonna have to
like literally like oh are you going on
the chick it's yeah but it's gonna be
like my whole salary like I don't care
like I'm going we went last time it was
like the best night of my life like
we're going but she was wrong sorry you
have to be able to love someone and
admit when they're wrong I agree and I
can do that but I think like we're
getting to the point in this in the
cycle of this story where they're gonna
come together
I look forward to it except Taylor does
not reconcile yeah she doesn't Katy
Perry has made numerous like I want to
get over it and she speaks about it a
lot publicly it's crazy learn never
speaks about the food it's crazy that
Katy and Taylor's fight is about backup
dancers know it's so stupid it's so
stupid whatever it's about left shark
that's a dancer well honestly I can
understand that fight yeah I think I'm
out of here
okay the last story I'm not doing fix
actually it's fine I'll do six Sandra
Bullock's stalker found dead after
five-hour standoff with the SWAT team
it's just like so sad it's like you
never expected like like these little
like things like to end in death it's
just like someone really loved Sandra
Bullock like I would do it and what if
by down to our stand-up with the SWAT
team he might have had the weapon he
ended up killing himself oh my goodness
doesn't look good oh my goodness drama I
hope she's okay she like been through so
she's been through so much it never
stops between Kat Von D and now her
stalker apparently someone told us like
when we went on that whole Kat Von D ran
thought like kapha he like never dated
Jesse James or something like we got the
whole thing wrong know that he didn't
on that Jesse James didn't cheat on her
with cat but now cat and Jesse are
together I think we still are I don't
know it's so confusing and honestly like
I couldn't care less about these people
I just wanted relate to Sandra I hope
that she's okay and like I just want her
and her like adorable son until I have
the best life together a green and I
kind of want to see oceans a it meaty
like I never had any interest in seeing
any of the oceans cuz honestly George
Clooney pisses the [ __ ] out of me like
he's annoying me what he did to Stacy
Keibler's but I'm like dad to see oceans
eight because I [ __ ] love Mindy
Kaling and like I'm just down no it
looks really I hope it is really good
because I could see it like getting so
much hype to her million hundreds of
million dollars in marketing and like
not being good no but like Rihanna's in
it's like it's gonna be good
and the Kardashians are in it yeah cuz
it's like a Met Gala
what was that member Olivia Munn is in
and she wound up having to like pay to
be in it because they want to pay her
and she'd pay for her transportation
here what is the movie where Kim play
someone's assistant miss it boy yeah
what's it called Kim was in a movie she
was also in disaster movie I never saw
that it's like one of those moon you
know how a temptation confessions of a
marriage counselor came and played
someone's assistant that's crazy
and she looks like so like trashy no you
know how there are those movies like a
scary movie and where the irony movie
series ass their movie was about like
world's ending movie and she like place
herself in like Nick Lachey is in it and
they're all at a party I think I just
love love love Kim and like her dynamic
abilities should I be a singer be a
reality star a businesswoman an actress
PS ik Jam you know oh my god I think
that's her literal biggest regret in
life no me too but and I love that she
talks about she's like who do they think
I was like that I could sing lol wait
before be challenged in our final story
I want to talk about watch happens I
have a saying go for it because it was
like the episode was basically made for
Amelia Michelle luck days after getting
engaged and Bethenny Frankel and
honestly like I was I wasn't going
through a mix of emotions where like I
never wanted the episode to end but like
also like I was feeling like I don't
want to say like a little disappointed
by Lea Michele
how so what did you expect I don't know
she's a huge housewives fan but she is
just a little boring like like Sheena
commentary to say like okay but here's
the thing she is one of like the most
talented people in happy overs of our
generation like sings acts beautiful if
she were also funny that just wouldn't
be fair no I totally agree but like for
me it was just like my favorite things
in the world and like I follow Lea
Michele on Instagram but like I never
get to like see her which is never a
reality she'll like doesn't do a bunch
of interviews like I never gets like
talked to her do you know anything so
much ribbons I was like this nice moment
where like I was just too excited like
all my worlds to kind of like connect
and I'm just like a little edgy I'm
Bethany obviously didn't let down she
looked amazing and she was being so
funny and like quippy I mean currently
Michele we're like really getting along
but likely Michele's like kind of like a
nerd like I could tell like and now you
know well together like I wouldn't be
from now you know why she doesn't have a
reality show you've never seen on
interviews and y-you don't know anything
about her I just love her and like I
really want good things for her like she
was really boring me he was fine there's
nothing wrong with like yeah boring
better than like being mean and being
sucky yeah okay the sauce story six
stories really sad
then I'm from roles cast supports Lala
Ken and her father's funeral oh my heart
breaks for her me too one week after the
reality TV star announced the death of
her father while returned home to Salt
Lake City Utah loves Holly city for his
memorial service on Thursday according
to social media photos castmates Ariana
Brittany Katie and Kristen made the trip
in honor of their close friend no Sheena
no Stassi because she's out of the
country by country Sheena has a show in
Vegas but like Vegas isn't far from some
they're just like not friends right now
I know but it's like these are the sort
of things where even if you're fighting
over dumps you just go you put it aside
and like come on Ronny yes exactly like
because you will get over your tub ship
but you'll never be able to take back or
like relive or be there for someone when
they needed you and that's all that
that's what life is about
I was never for people when they need
you and if you're not there then who
gives a [ __ ] when you are
I was following along with Lala on
snapchat and she was wearing one of her
dad's shirt and ties and she looked so
bad yeah there's this picture here she's
wearing her dad shirt and tie she says
dad shirt
hi representing my pops today as we
celebrate his life he was an epic human
can I read you like literally the
saddest tweet ever from Jax yeah yeah
okay can you pull it up with Jackson no
I don't have a needed a picture of an
empty shot glass at a bar I was like if
Jackson's dad passed away a few months
ago and they were like super close and
he was like dad I miss you so much every
day like I pretend like I'm okay but
like I'm really hurting inside I miss
you so much please take care of Lala's
dad like it felt like a little kid like
writing a letter to Santa you know what
I mean like it was so pathetic I'm like
so sad like and I like retweeted it like
it was just like that's like proof like
say me want about Jax I love him and I
think he's a good person I well we'll
talk about that in a second but people
are saying scheana was there okay well
enews is not saying scheana was there I
believe you guys over E news but you
know we didn't like make that up good
I'm glad she's there because that's what
counts
yeah um Jax you know that I said this so
many times and we talked about this on
patreon how we are able because we're
just incredible two separate people on
TV from when they come in the show what
they are like in real life and decisions
that they make on TV and Jax is also one
of those people because I think that he
is a really like decent person too and I
think one he makes bad choices on TV and
two he knows he's on TV like he's
wearing this he's playing a part almost
right and I remember getting that he the
interview that he did with complex and
every time he does something [ __ ] up
on TV it's all I think about where it's
like he knows that he has this
opportunity and like he's going to ride
this wave and girls isn't gonna last
forever
and then he's moving back to Florida
with his woman and that's that you guys
shouldn't read this interview with
complex because it was like in the Navy
it explains a lot about him honestly and
also then just knowing him and he's
always been such a nice guy so like
every time we see him I'm telling you
Jax it's like one of the most
misunderstood people of her generation
but he's also kind of brilliant cuz it's
like he if he's able to separate what he
does on TV from his real life and like
it's almost like he's an actor his
Twitter it's almost like he's an actor
he is he's on a hit television show
playing a part and now he like crucified
it's a mouse cashes those Bravo checks
yeah keep cashing those checks so him
it's interesting to see like
from the original cast is still on the
show and like if Tom Schwartz wasn't an
original cast member even though he's
been on since the beginning so like I
think the longer you've been on the show
you are making the most money yeah but
like Stassi was an original character
but she took a one-year break and then
what I heard was that after the one of
your break she had to start her salary
back from the beginning so like if you
think about it the only people on the
show who have been full-time cast member
since the beginning it's like Katie
scheana Sanibel Jax mm-hmm Kristen but
she doesn't work at Sur so she's not
yeah only them poor but I don't see the
season finale but they said Jax quit Sur
and this is the finale
really cuz I was making less money I
have to catch up no because like the
show well the show thinks that they need
him and I think he thinks that he needs
the show but I think the show needs to
evolve did you need to evolve but he's
still like a funny character like like
his commentary or the season like I'm
watching and like it's really boring
that like Mike can't drink or like party
but he's still so funny and like I stand
by what I said that like he really made
the show in the beginning and like he
made them a family he gave them like
this lingo and they all started like
creating this weird kind of vocabulary
and he still has that like I mean he was
insulting Ronny it was so funny like
even though he's not he's still bringing
something to the table and I think Jax
even though yes he's still involved in
the drama he brings like a funny levity
to the table like when him and James are
friends it's so in he goes drowning
drowning
I don't know I mean like he really liked
experience as a near-death experience
it's pretty like he was really dying it
was crazy and it's like everyone's
laughing at him and then I feel like his
approach to life changed like I thought
like he saw it he'd like was near death
was he drowning or he was like having
pains in his pain that having trouble
breathing because of the one he was out
of breath and the altitude and then he
couldn't swim right right right no no I
understand
no yeah like I just I think he's a good
character and like I just I enjoy him
like who's someone you can do without on
man I'm a pearls
well first I could do I can do without
Tom Tom the bar situation I actually
fast forward all of those scenes and oh
boy they test for them when I watch them
and then when I was watching like
sometimes I watch a reruns and I'll see
you seen him like I never saw
[Laughter]
um and I could also do without it
depends because like sometimes I feel
like I could do without like the Kristin
like yeah but then she brings like the
James drama that I know that I need like
sometimes I'm like I could definitely do
without Sheena because she's annoying
but like hey we met her and she was so
nice and be like what would we be
talking about this season if you weren't
talking about hanging a TV in seven
minutes and Madison parks Valletta right
you know like so in her weird quirkiness
like she actually makes the show
hilarious
agreed and like kind of like her like
lack of self-awareness sometimes it's
like just right they give everyone was
like Lala like what would we talk about
right cuz Lala's like so reserved like
almost like Erika Jayne I method I was
making the comparison more and more cuz
I was catching up on Beverly Hills and
meadow from pearls yesterday I'm like I
think that Lala is a Erika Jayne in the
making
I agree dating an older man looks
finance is your business but you're
actually talented and you're gonna be a
singer and you're like beautiful you
have an amazing about any like really
interesting style and like you're just
like a boss and like you don't care what
other people say about you like I think
that they're mother-daughter like I'm
telling you wait oh my god good call
also it's like Lala is you know her I
don't wanna mana but then she's also
like going to Sundance with Randall and
like that is like near Erika Jayne
performing at the Palm Springs white
party but then also going to like the
the law of ball with Tom Girardi totally
I think that if she plays her cards
right if Bravo knows what's good she
could end up on Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills I would be so here for it
what would be like the oh he's just
really young yeah but their audiences
yeah yeah no no I know I'm just saying
like I know so she's not as young as you
think she's 27 so maybe if in three
years know that she was like 24 Meghan
King Edmonds started know she's like I
think around my age so she I started
when she was like 29 or 30 and Meghan
King Edmonds started when she was like
32 Kim Zolciak is so young I know I
don't think she's like 80 because she's
100 kids but she's at 35 and also cuz
she's been on our TVs forever for so
long that's crazy I know it almost seems
like she couldn't fake her age at this
point cuz we all know when she started
that's like someone went so II that
really blew my mind is Adele is the same
age as Taylor Swift that blew my mind
when they told I'm the same age as Carly
Rae Jepsen things that are the same age
um also but then the opposite is like
Lisa Vanderpump
I think she's 70 but apparently she's
like 45 yeah no she is 192 years old
she's from she's biblical it's like
everything she does to me I'm like when
they go on those trips I'm like how does
Lisa Vanderpump like have like withstand
it no no like how does she have the
stamina to like take these trips with
these ladies and like work and see a
heart and have a fight I don't know
because like I could barely do it like
in real life without cameras right and
she has to get all dolled up and by the
way I was thinking she never brings glam
yeah does she do her own hair I just
can't see it no me neither just can't
see it her like reaching the back pieces
of her hair like I can't she I think
they all bring glam but like they all
bring a person or Bravo likes type and
Simon Says hair and makeup to everyone's
room with Doreen and Erica bring teens I
think Teddy definitely does her own
makeup totally and actually know Kyle
sometimes has to you're right and Kyle I
think does makeup well Kyle is insanely
beautiful hair that's true and I also
think that some ladies don't like
cameras and when they're getting ready
like I would I don't I don't ever
remember a moment like where someone
comes in to talk to Lisa Vanderpump
she's getting her makeup like she always
just shows up ready never seen her
without makeup right we're hair but like
Kyle I even remember where she was
getting her bob done I just I've seen
her getting her hair and makeup done and
I've seen her without makeup that's true
like even when they work out never works
out with them no she does but like
barely that's what I was apparently Lau
as 28 okay so two more years housewife
material I'm here tele Mellencamp is 36
Teddy Mellencamp is the same age as Jax
and chef know Jax is older that's just
four days chef chef and her and Teddy
and Shep grew up together Jax isn't
crazy
Jax has been hinting on his Twitter that
him and Shep are like working on the
show I'm here for what would it be
maybe they should do like relationship I
don't know for Jax is in relationship
and I think I would just because that
would be up the recipe sir they would be
when disaster day Thursday I'm so tired
such a long weekend so many birthdays
it's yours expert day Olivia Zach's
birthday and Margo watches 21st
also there are still some tickets
available to my Caroline show and I'm
not trying to be annoying but they're
only VIP tickets sorry general admission
tickets are sold out in there 100
so wanted to make it worthwhile because
I control ours is a lot so here's what
I'm doing if you already bought a VIP
ticket or if you're going to buy B you
take it because there's like 50 left you
are automatically entered into a contest
and what you include in that contest is
all the people who buy VIP tickets I'm
gonna choose 10 people and those 10
people are gonna be able to come to a
toast to taping they could sit right
there
enjoy clap all that stuff they're also
gonna be invited to a boozy brunch with
Ben and I I don't know where I'm gonna
do it yet maybe the wayfarer delicious
yeah oh my goodness my drink is dripping
occasion really cool defense and then
the third thing you've got a swag bag
with like I'm literally gonna bawl it
out with like my favorite makeup product
sound like always like slinging on my
Instagram and some exclusive toast merch
that no one's gotten yet so it's gonna
be really cool ten people are getting
chosen which is like really good ratio
because there's like not that many
tickets so yeah Caroline's calm girls no
job thanks May 10th 11th I'm really
excited for toast merch I'm will be like
network we need to be at work to do that
we have all the ideas yeah I'm so it's
honestly if you guys are in the toaster
screen but if you just want to treated
us like any ideas you have for March
like we want to make it like like
emerges like taken merch in like general
has just like evolved like when we used
to go to concerts when I get t-shirts
with like all the dates on the back like
that was so losery like I just thought
Taylor Swift released a video of like
how much and it's like styling like I
gots really you don't like it no but
like it has style it's not just a
teacher but it's like it's like the Rev
Justin Bieber Nicki Minaj's tour merge
cells at H&M like it's clothing
Kanye's well yeah look I just love that
merchants like kings so I want our merch
to be like style in wild right I'm not
living in a sweater shirt that says at
the morning toast on to say it Laurent
gotta kiss myself I'm so pretty
too hot hot damn call the police and the
fireman too hot hot damn make a dragon
wanna retire man I'm too hot hot damn
say my name You Know Who I am too hot
hot damn I'm a band about that money
break it down girls hallelujah cause
uptown funk don't give it oh my god I'm
shaking my shoulders like Lisa
Vanderpump oh yeah I know I have nothing
to gain I had one more thought oh my god
someone commented
anything in the toasters group that they
had a dream about us and that we sold
merch a t-shirt that says belly bottle
and had a scratch-and-sniff belly button
how would you spell believe it all
you definitely need some accent so manly
a BL I with the tilde mu with the you
with the dot yeah talk over the oh yeah
don't talk you don't even in the end at
the end yes you guys thank you so much
for tuning in today it has been a true
pleasure hosting you this morning I'm
Claudia are a girl with no job I'm
Jackie ashtray Jackie oh problems we are
back tomorrow morning the morning breath
whoo the morning toast is live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
we go live on Facebook we go live on
YouTube and our episodes are uploaded in
the podcast app a little later that day
so make sure you're subscribed to on
YouTube you like on us on Facebook and
you leave a review about how beautifully
stunning and gorgeous we are in the
podcast app and if five days a week
isn't enough for you we're also
available on patreon where for a dollars
a month you can get 5 extra episodes
podcast only and they're supremely
premium patreon.com forward slash the
morning toast I am four shows at
Caroline's please come and I finally
released my YouTube video it was about a
week late but like about half a watch
and I didn't do how to anyways got a
chubby physique by the way you should
have called it
QVC had a chubby fist h HSN how to
maintain it was so key bc why are these
rings so that you'll get compliments if
the wazoo oh my god that is so funny
like were you intentionally being like
home shopping or she's like trying to
show the outfit it just happened some of
us are just natural sellers I got you
and Lisa Rinna yeah okay toast to okay
you know what on toast you lalla Ken's
dad is that what you're gonna say
because we met her she was such an angel
she brought her mom like she's obviously
really family-oriented and I just feel
like this is breaking her and from
one-half orphan to another Tyra still on
thank you guys for tuning in we will see
you tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow
[Music]
you